and yes
that is your hand in our way very good
who knew auditions for director james
gunn could involve intense chemistry
tests with rats the suicide squad actors
went through some unique experiences
when it came to getting their roles most
of them didn't even know which character
they were auditioning for which actor
joined the cast solely because of the
name of his character let's take a look
i hope so daniella melchior's audition
experience was actually a pretty
extensive affair it was lucky that she
ended up with an in-person audition
since she'd actually passed on two
different self-tape requests for the
film and finally submitted an audition
when the third opportunity came around
while being on vacation led her to
passing on the tapes deep down she was
really nervous about auditioning in
english
this was her first full-length english
language movie the actress admits it's
one of the worst tapes she'd ever done
she actually read her script right off
the paper on camera
a major no-no for such a huge gig but
something stuck and she was flown to the
production team to meet in person
before even getting into the audition
room daniella melchior had an in-person
meeting with james gunn and peter
saffron while she was going to be
auditioning to play a loner rat
controller her agent suggested she do
full makeup for this major and
potentially career changing meeting the
glammed up first impression made the
team think that she wasn't the right fit
for the part and even got her a no after
the meeting luckily melchior had one
more shot to impress when she showed up
to read for rat catcher 2. the actress's
chemistry test with a rat turned out to
be what did the trick after seeing her
enthusiasm with the rodents the team saw
her in a totally new light
that no very quickly became a yes and
the rest is history i picked one up and
then he was crawling my on my shoulder
margot robbie's impact on the dc eu has
been remarkable the actress's portrayal
of harley quinn is brilliant and she
once said she'd be keen to do the role
as long as possible it is a dream job
and robbie fits it pretty perfectly a
definite match made in dceu heaven
robbie is also one of the few actors to
do both suicide squad and the suicide
squad so her being cast was discussed
quite a bit rumors even went around that
the studio might have forced james gunn
to bring her on as harley quinn but
fortunately none of this was true gunn
went so far as to call margot robbie the
best actor i've ever worked with bar
none the rave review isn't a surprise
since robbie didn't even audition for
the part in the first place i didn't
lose audition which is
a real step up as an actor when you can
get offered things looks like one thing
everyone can agree on is that robbie
makes a pretty brilliant harley quinn
oh
storm reid might be 17 years old but her
resume is already long and impressive so
it's no surprise she was brought onto
the film to play idris elba's sassy
daughter it was pretty perfect casting
since the actress feels like she meets
the same level of sass and swag as her
character funnily enough it took quite a
while before reed actually learned who
she was playing only having a name to
work with and of course idris alba
the actress adored working with him elba
actually helped keep her on her toes
quite a bit on set reed said she was
really impressed by how quickly alba
would move in and out of character
especially since he was so friendly and
talkative when he wasn't performing they
would call cut he would just like go
back into conversation and laugh and
talk john cena wasn't the only actor
considered to play peacemaker initially
dave bautista was who the team wanted
since james gunn had worked with him on
guardians of the galaxy but it didn't
work out due to some scheduling
conflicts
that's when gunn brought up joining the
dc franchise to the actor it was a
no-brainer for cena while the actor
didn't know a whole lot about what he
was getting into he knew who james gunn
was and that his eye for casting was a
step above the rest so he trusted his
gut and dove right in
cena wasn't let down as when the two met
up director gunn blew the actor away
with just how prepared and passionate
about the material he was
this was definitely a leap of faith
worth taking well um i am a horrible
superhero so uh it's it's quite
difficult pete davidson was pumped to
join the suicide squad even if his
appearance in the film is fairly
short-lived how exactly did the actor
get involved
director james gunn gave him a call
letting him know that there was a role
he could play in the movie
once gunn explained the name of his
character would be richard hertz
davidson called the character dick hertz
there was no turning back after that
davidson was all in when you get to work
with james gunn on a superhero movie
it's kind of like getting work with dr
dre with making a hip hop out when idris
alba initially signed on to be part of
the suicide squad he wasn't sure exactly
which character he'd be playing instead
of rushing to choose a character the
team took their time and really explored
their options making sure the character
they chose would be the best fit so
until that was sorted out idris elba
went by vigilante the production team
knew people would be snooping to get
more info so code names were used pretty
widely during the production we didn't
know what character from the dc universe
we were going to use
nathan fillion and director james gunn
working together on the suicide squad
was a pretty logical step considering
the two have been long time
collaborators they first met years ago
when filian was auditioning for a film
in 2006 called slither the movie was
being filmed in vancouver and before he
left the audition fillion dropped the
fact that he was canadian and was
convinced that that played a part in
booking the job after a pretty rocky
experience working on slither fillian
was impressed with how well gunn handled
every single issue and really knew that
he could trust this director now he
takes any opportunity he can to work
with him when borg went into his
audition for the suicide squad he had no
idea he'd be auditioning for javelin
since the character had been given a
different name to prevent any leaks from
getting out with the name of the
character he auditioned for being
different and random foam instruments in
the audition room borg felt totally
thrown the actor feels like he very
accidentally struck the right tone in
the room
it was such an uncertain affair that
borg felt like he was accidentally given
a job but that wouldn't stop him from
taking it and loving it getting cast in
the dc eu was an absolute dream come
true
even if he felt it was all accidental
once the role was his he put loads of
work in eating 7 000 calories a day and
training to be in shape to throw the
javelin like a pro germans happen to be
very strong javelin throwers so borg
really knew he had to work to live up to
the expectation
i love your accent when acting legend
sylvester stallone was called by
director james gunn he wasn't so much
asked as he was told that he'd be
voicing a role in the suicide squad
since gunn had written it for him once
stallone knew it wouldn't be too much of
a time commitment gunn explained the
character he was voicing would be a
chubby shark that eats humans stallone
was all in and sealed the deal with
anything for you brother he's such a
misfit he's like a shark out of water
can it be worse one day mei ling got a
call from her agent letting her know
that she had an audition just three days
later with no details but james gunn and
creature talk about intimidating the
audition felt really intense for the
actress and she felt like she'd totally
miss the mark she even found herself
fully growling at one point once she got
the offer and found out she was going to
be playing mongol she realized that the
audition she did was pretty perfect for
the character a surprisingly common
theme amongst many of the cast members
in the suicide squad think there's any
connection
no this cast blew the film out of the
water knowing just how unsure some of
these actors were during the audition
process is pretty wild it's obvious
director james gunn has a knack for
casting and actors seem to love working
with him who else could call sylvester
stallone with the offer to play a chubby
shark